I think if you ask every man in the
world every single one when we were
about 10 years old or 11 years old
how do you want to live when you're in
your late 20s early 30s like in 20 years
time where do you want to be they'd all
say the same thing they'd say I want a
giant house I want lots of pretty women
I want to drive around in fast cars
that's what they would say now I find a
lot of men in the positions of a lot of
men who attack people like me for living
my lifestyle
I find a position wholly dishonest
because they've had the dream that they
did have as a young boy every single
young boy had the exact injury they've
had this dream beaten out of them by bad
relationships uh I don't know lack of
ambition working their crappy job
getting fat whatever it is they've done
in their life that has shrunk the
possibility of this dream happening for
them they then internalize their anger
and they
burst out at people like me I treat
everybody from from the waiter to my to
my housekeepers uh to my security with
the absolute utmost respect I'm loyal to
the point where I will never ever uh
stab a friend in the back uh talk I mean
that's just general
um the way the way I live my life you
know I take very good care of my mother
I take very good care of my daughter the
journey is massively important because
you know today we're in a bit of
situation where a lot of people from
Basic things like a pumping
cryptocurrency can make too much money
without learning any of the lessons of
life but some people basically get get
lucky it's like winning the lottery if
you've bought some crypto coin and now
you have like a hundred million dollars
because you caught some crazy pump I
mean yeah cool you were you had the
foresight to buy that coin but tens of
thousands of other people put money into
other coins that didn't blow up it's
it's essentially like a lottery win and
when I see young guys who are two
um who are too wealthy at such a young
age from doing something that took so
little skill and so little hardship I
just know that they are not prepared to
have that kind of money like all right
you you have millionaire you are a
millionaire but you don't know what it
takes to be a millionaire because you've
never had to go through any struggle and
uh yeah the the journey is super
important uh the the setbacks and the
bad things that happen to you make you
stronger sharper are more intelligent
people don't develop any knowledge or
culture if they run into money too fast
so the question you need to ask yourself
before you go into any of this is is
what are you doing this for what are you
doing this for are you doing it to make
yourself happy because that's the way
you should be living your life you are
number one and you should be you know
living a life that you find fulfilling
and you find enjoyable I've lost
everybody I needed to lose over the last
10 years I've lost them all already when
I was on my way up I lost all the people
who you know I needed to shake off
anyway all the all the friends were
hangers on all the people who weren't
really happy for me when I did well so
my my Friendship Circle in my friendship
group has always been very strong
um and I always knew that the people I
could count on I could count on them so
yeah you got to be a good person man
because it comes around and if you're a
bad person that comes around too money
doesn't change somebody reveals who they
really are that's one I've definitely
found and I can talk more about that but
there's loads of things I can say about
my philosophy of life because I haven't
changed poor or Rich and I was broken
now I'm rich as [ __ ] I haven't changed
one percent I'm exactly the same person
I've always been I I know people who ran
into a little bit of money and became
and people like oh yeah Money Changes
people no it doesn't he was always
saying oh he just didn't have the
platform of the balls or the or the ego
to say it to say what he really thought
I think it really depends on what kind
of person you are I think money is an
accelerant if you're a depressed sad
um you know person I believe you if you
give a depressed sad person 10 million
dollars they're gonna end up suicidal
and if you give a very happy content
fulfilled person 10 million dollars
they're going to be more happy more
content more fulfilled I think it's an
accelerator so it really depends on
where you are in life when people say
things like money doesn't buy happiness
I would say yes it actually does if you
know what to buy follow your passions
because you like some if your passion is
making money good when people say oh do
what you're passionate about Follow Your
Passion now I would say do what you're
good at do your competent at but don't
necessarily you're like like uh do you
think aliko dang toys Nigeria's richest
man he made his money in concrete I
think he gives about concrete no no he's
a billionaire so no don't follow your
passion that's what I would say it's
like your passion might be your passion
might be one of those passions that just
keeps people broke and I think
kickboxing is is a very important part
of our foundational story and my
foundational story uh because it just
you know made me realize that there were
higher mountains to climb because it's
sometimes takes money to make money and
with the millions of dollars that we had
we made some very smart Investments and
we started running other businesses look
genetics intellect wit and I mean there
are various things that we're all born
with and when you get to the age of 12
13 you could see who's becoming a man
with physicality who's becoming a man
who's smart yes some people have further
to go than other people I know people
who are genetically West genetically
blessed guys who never ever trained in
they've got iron six packs of big arms
all the time that guy obviously does not
have to try as hard as the skinny little
dork to be physically attractive to
women he has to try probably not very
hard at all maybe he's six foot four
like me let me tell you something
everybody can get there
if you're dumb you can get smarter if
you are weak you can get stronger
it's just some people are so far gone in
terms of being a strong guy they're two
out of ten now instead of realizing that
they need to work in the gym three hours
a day every day for five years to be a
physically imposing man they think oh
well I've got the genetics I give up so
yeah you can actually
you can actually turn a geek into a stop
oh how can I make money or how do I make
a millionaire what the secrets to
success
there is no secret to success I have the
secret to my success and the secret to
my success is different from the secret
to everyone else's success what I would
say is my financial advice I give to
everybody including How I Live Today is
I spend I mean I did ten thousand
dollars in the club the other day I
spend half of my money like I'm gonna
live 50 more years and half of my money
like I'm gonna live 50 more days because
you know what I might only live 50 more
days you know no no one knows and life
is very very short so I think if you you
know put all your money in the bank
saving for a rainy day you might just
can you even just die with millions of
dollars in the bank you know never have
never ever having a been that guy who
you know had a Ferrari or had a
Lamborghini even though you've had the
money and then no one's ever gonna you
know then you didn't you didn't squeeze
the all the juice out of the lemon of
life and you know a lot of people can do
it and you know some rappers Etc talk
about oh hit it and quit it but they
will never get the true enjoyment of of
male female relationships they'll never
get it because they'll never have women
who actually fall in love with them if
you want to go around treating people
like it you're never gonna have any
friends have any girlfriends everyone's
going to be out to use you and what goes
around comes around so yeah be nice I
say it all the time you know the the
money to to live this lifestyle is very
very important I went through a phase
when I was completely flat broke but I
was a kickboxer I was working hard I was
staying focused in a very bad town where
a lot of people were very bad people and
that was a different era that era is
over that era is completely over uh
what's happened is uh we're we're 15
years ago 14 years ago it was possible
to meet a girlfriend you know date a
girl who was pretty
and she didn't have access to all the
millionaires in the world there was a
pretty girl from Luton Town Instagram
you know exactly where whereas nowadays
if you're a young man you're 17 18 19
you go get your money game right and you
have to have a lifestyle that is at
least interesting to women because the
same woman that you would have taken out
20 years ago that you would have had
access to maybe you go to university
with her maybe you just finished high
school with her she's now being hit up
by people like me uh and you know and
who she's going to choose so yeah making
the money and getting your finances
right is super super important to living
a life uh but I picked this picture on
purpose because that way I find that
when people judge you uh just like they
judge you or any of your friends or
anyone you know they're not really
judging you they're judging at this
character that you've created for the
world to see so they can take your
opinion their opinion and you know do
whatever they want with it but it
doesn't it doesn't resonate anymore
human beings were social animals at the
end of the day you know no one is truly
happy when you I mean we lock people in
little rooms by themselves as punishment
and there's reason that's a punishment
and not and not a reward it's uh we are
social creatures yeah it's very normal
to feel like you need somebody around
you and it's very normal to feel that
way when you're single
[Music]